all right we're going to start today
with what many of you emailed me about
with very different opinions
um this is the news that youtube has now
officially banned all anti-vaccine
content and even some
sort of perennial anti-vaccine content
creators and
some of you emailing me saying this is
absolutely horrifying even though i'm
pro-vaccine many of you said
um allowing youtube to be the arvid
arbiter of what counts as an
anti-vaccine or not is very problematic
others wrote to me and said david is is
this really a big deal or not
and the answer is that this is a major
content decision but what's being missed
by many of the articles and many of the
people emailing me is that it's not much
of a change to youtube's content policy
around anti-vaccine content this
this has been 90 the policy for the last
many many months anyway
and this actually represents a pretty
minor change so let's look at some of
the reporting on this um reuters writing
youtube blocks all anti-vaccine content
youtube will block all anti-vaccine
content moving beyond its ban on false
information about the covet vaccines to
include content that contains
misinformation about other approved
vaccines it said in a blog post on
wednesday
examples of content that won't be
allowed on youtube include claims that
the flu vaccine causes infertility and
that the mmr shot the measles mumps
rubella shot can cause autism the online
video company owned by alphabet google
is also banning channels associated with
several prominent anti-vaccine activists
including
robert f kennedy jr
and joseph mercola a youtube
spokesperson said
um the move comes as youtube and tech
giants like facebook and twitter have
been criticized for not doing enough to
stop the spread of false information
but even as youtube takes a tougher
stance it faces backlash around the
world russian state-backed broadcaster
rt's german language channels were
deleted from youtube as the company said
the channels breached its coveted
misinformation policy russia called the
move unprecedented information
aggression and threatened to block
youtube
now i have to tell you guys
this is barely a change in policy from
what's been the case for a long time and
there's also some confusion about
banning content versus demonetizing
content let's look at one more article
and then we're going to get into those
details uh nbc article
says
youtube cracks down on anti-vaccine
videos bans major accounts
youtube announced a total ban wednesday
on vaccine misinformation and the
termination of accounts of several
prominent anti-vaccine influencers i
already named them joseph mercola robert
f kennedy jr the new policy was crafted
as the company began to see false claims
about covet 19 vaccines spill over into
misinformation about vaccines in general
youtube already had a policy against
covet vaccine misinformation but the new
ban against broader vaccine
misinformation includes content that
falsely claims approved vaccines are
dangerous or ineffective including the
false belief that vaccines cause autism
or cancer so the most important line in
all of these articles is that this
policy already existed with relation to
covet vaccines
the this is only a tweak
in that now more general anti-vaccine
stuff will also be banned
99
of the quote problematic content over
the last eight nine months since the
covet vaccines have been out has been
related specifically to covet vaccines
and that has already been banned
whether it's impo enforced and policed
in every case on such a large platform
is a different question but
what
most people are reacting to
is
reacting as if this is
about covet vaccine stuff specifically
the covet vaccine disinformation has
already been banned this is now
expanding it like two percent to say
in general cove vaccine misinformation
not covavectin vaccine misinformation is
now going to be banned as well
also the vast majority of youtube
content is allowed
uh but some of it is not monetizable and
that's another aspect of this that many
people are being confused by there's a
whole bunch of stuff
that is what we would call edgy
in in a for for lack of a better term
which is allowed on youtube the vast
majority of content is allowed on
youtube but you can't monetize all of it
and that applies to me as well there's
stuff that's
too edgy that i cover uh related to war
or conflicts terrorism that's not
monetizable but it's allowed and the
vast majority of even kind of like edgy
content um is allowed but not
necessarily monetizable so i have to
tell you
i think this is mostly much ado about
nothing
i think facebook is a lot more to blame
for this stuff than youtube youtube
actually has been cracking down on
conspiracy misinformation for a while
now maybe not as much as they should
have been if there's a criticism it's
they haven't done enough
um they've gone out of their way to
provide official information about
coronavirus vaccines etc when the
algorithm detects that that's the
subject matter was it enough no
but i'm seeing way more problematic
stuff spread and be signal boosted on
facebook
where it's really generating even more
denialism and perpetuating this
information and one of the things i've
been thinking about a lot lately and i
know this is a big statement
at this point i think facebook is is
probably a net negative probably a net
negative i think
youtube is still a net positive okay
there's so much amazing instructional
and documentary content cooking
gardening so so many things on on uh
youtube that are just fantastic and
there are problems with misinformation
spreading on youtube as well
i'm just not sure that facebook is at
all a net positive we still publish to
facebook because i i think
facebook exists and i'd rather facebook
have our content than not have it but
that's a real question for me at this
point in time if that topic is
interesting by the way i highly
recommend the book technopoly by the
critic neil postman i'm almost done
reading it
he's way more straight up like
anti-technology than i am but the book
which is actually from the 90s perfectly
predicts the conundrum we're in with
social media platforms right now and the
downsides of tech and it's very much a
worthwhile read now as far as the
decision by youtube either way the
conspiracy theorists were going to say
youtube is against them they ban the
content the anti-vaxxers say youtube is
participating in the suppression
but they'd say it either way
and so i think that this is definitely
the right decision is there some concern
about who gets to decide what counts as
anti-vaxx sure yeah at any time you know
being the gatekeeper
uh brings with it its own set of
questions and problems that's always a
problem it's not new here and you don't
say
that these companies can't enforce terms
of service in terms and conditions as a
result
and unfortunately that's the that's the
claim that many are making
i absolutely love this next story
the supporters of that completely bogus
audit of the 2020 presidential election
results in arizona
are now turning on each other after the
total embarrassing humiliating flop
in which after months and months of
saying this audit will show us what
really happened
um the results were joe biden actually
won arizona by about 360 i believe
additional votes than what was
originally reported and as per usual
when things go bad trump supporters just
start attacking each other and blaming
daily beast article explains arizona
audit backers turn on each other
after the recount flop um our former
guest of on on the show will summer
wrote this article supporters of
republicans controversial quote audit i
think it makes sense to put that in
quotes we still don't really know is is
this an audit what is an audit
supporters of the audit have turned on
each other
after the partisan investigation failed
to find proof of election malfeasance
with disaffected backers even
circulating a fabricated rival report
they claim shows interference by the
quote deep state
the audit report landed with a thud on
friday only proving if anything that joe
biden won arizona by more votes than
previously realized on this week's
episode of the daily beast fever dreams
podcast hosts esawin subsang and will
summer are joined by arizona mirror
reporter jared mcdonald devoid to
discuss the fractious aftermath some
people who were involved in the report
say the deep state kept the real truth
out now that's already great because
they're essentially some of the people
who supported the audit are saying the
deep state infiltrated their own group
and their own audit that would raise
questions as to whether that's a very
trustworthy group to be doing this at
all if they could be so easily
infiltrated by the deep state
uh the deep state and the politically
correct lawyers and rhinos of the
republican party suppressed this
said mcdonald avoid
summarizing right-wing critics
complaints about the anti-climactic
audit report
among the audit reports new detractors
jovan hutton pulitzer the controversial
inventor whose supposed technology
analyzing full whose supposed technology
analyzing folds in paperback in ballot
paper had promised to detect some kind
of fraud instead the final audit report
contained no mention of pulitzer's
imaging technology a change pulitzer
attributed on twitter to deep state
malfeasance asked over email who in the
deep state supposedly sabotaged his
contribution pulitzer remained vague
vague that's the big question is it not
this is just amazing
right-wing media personalities
disappointed by the audit have even
promoted a fictitious rival report they
claim was the real report from the audit
operators cyberninjas in this telling
the fabricated draft report called for
biden's win to be decertified but while
the fake report was embraced by the
right-wing news blog gateway pundit as
proof that the real report had been
watered down
cyber ninjas blasted that report as a
hoax i think you guys understand
um they are eating each other
uh and there's a big analogy here to the
flat earthers if you get a bunch of flat
earthers in a room together
they all believe the earth is flat
but they cite different proofs supposed
proofs explaining why and we talked
about this actually uh recently on the
show
and some of their alleged proofs
conflict with each other they can't
possibly be true yeah
they'll all agree the earth is flat
but they will disagree vehemently or
vehemently as to what evidence there is
for that and there's a very sort of
similar thing here the audit failed to
point to trump actually winning they're
blaming each other they've got
conflicting reports and sometimes you
have to eat your own to maintain the lie
that's sort of what they were signing up
for here and consider
the backfire and the fact that the audit
was not just a waste of time it was a
waste of money and it actually ended up
showing if anything that donald trump
was an even bigger loser in
arizona than we originally thought
uh will the results be any different
from other audits well in texas they're
auditing counties in a state that trump
already won
so my prediction is no if you think
anything will come of any of these
audits if you even understand what it
means that they are doing auditing
i would love to hear from you you can
find me on twitter at deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
alright so there was a hearing yesterday
really over the last couple of days and
uh secretary of defense lloyd austin was
questioned by members of congress the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
general mark milley was questioned and
this
hearing
was the epitome
of showboating
and grandstanding to no benefit
whatsoever of the american people full
stop there's barely more of an
there's almost no additional analysis to
do
other than many of these members of
congress really have no business being
in congress and you'll very quickly
figure out which individuals those are
much of the hearing was meant to
just provide a cartoonish opportunity
for people like matt gates and others
to demand and or request
that general mark milly
resign and they couched it as being
related to afghanistan although the
topic of mark milley having to sort of
reassure china that trump is not going
to just bomb you in the last few days of
his presidency
uh that's a story that we we learned
about as a result um of this uh book by
carol lennog and philip brucker i
believe it is uh let's just get right
into the clips it's it's really amazing
here is uh congressman joe wilson
who calls for president joe biden to
resign just countless calls for
resignations during these hearings buck
stops with 13 murdered marines mr biden
the gentleman's disregarding the
military advice and i believe the
president should resign
i'm prepared to begin my questions i
believe the president should resign
everybody should resign according to
these hearings
then and this is actually really
important milly actually explains
what it was that led him to
communicate with chinese officials in
those final days of the trump presidency
and congressman hartzler republican from
missouri says milly should resign look
at this many others
uh that the chinese thought
wrongly
that the united states is going to
attack them i am certain guaranteed
certain that president trump had no
intent to attack and it was my task to
make sure i communicated that
and the purpose was to de-escalate
confidence he shared all that earlier
understanding that just say did you or
did you sorry and i think i said
congressman hartzler it's congresswoman
hearts laura i think i misspoke before
ask tell him that if we were going to
attack you would let him know as part of
that conversation i said generally
there's not going to be a war there's
not going to be attack between great
powers and if there was the tensions
would build up there'd be calls going
back and forth from all kinds of senior
officials i said hell generally i'll
probably give you a call but we're not
going to attack you trust me we're not
going to attack you
these are two great powers and i am
doing my best to transmit the
president's intent
so understand that the right wants to
frame what millie did as some kind of
treason
by calling china and saying we're not
going to attack you no matter what
which then would be a signal to china
hey the u.s isn't going to attack us no
matter what now it's a carte blanche for
us to do stuff what milly is explaining
is he called and he said listen in these
last few days
trump's not going to just start dropping
random bombs on you if we were going to
get into a military conflict there would
be an escalation we would be talking the
way that things happened there would be
threats there would be an escalation
that is obviously not the treason that
the right one wants to make it out to be
but hartzler doesn't care it's intent to
ensure that the american people are
protected from an incident that could
escalate
i understand your intent but i think you
articulating that that you would tell
him you would give him a call i think is
worthy of your resignation
um i just think that's against our
country that you would give our number
one adversary
that information and tell him that these
people they're either idiots or they're
pretending but there is
it's
there there's just nothing there there's
i don't know how else to say it then
matt gates gets involved then it gets
even more embarrassing february 26 2020
house armed services committee general
mark milley
we know we're not going to defeat the
taliban militarily and they're not going
to defeat the government of afghanistan
militarily
you really blew that call didn't you
general
i believe that that was a
issue of strategic stalemate and that if
we had remained in afghanistan
uh with the advisory levels of effort
than the government of afghanistan
that's that's an interesting answer to a
question it's just not one i asked you
spent more time with bob woodward on
this book than you spent analyzing the
very likely prospect that the
afghanistan government was going to fall
immediately to the taliban didn't you
not even close congressman oh really
because you said right after kabul fell
that no one could have anticipated the
immediate fall of the ghani government
when did you become aware that joe biden
tried to get ghani to lie about the
conditions in afghanistan he did that in
july did you know that right away
i'm not aware of
what president biden you're not aware of
the phone call that biden had with gani
where he said whether it is true or not
we want you to go out there and paint a
rosy picture of what's going on in
afghanistan you're the chief military
adviser to the president you said that
the taliban was not going to defeat the
government of afghanistan militarily
which by the way they cut through him
like a hot knife through butter it was
just endlessly like this just gates is
is horrible
and then gates mentions as an aside
that biden is too addled to even fire
anyone
uh but that they should be
uh they shouldn't be in their positions
it it just it gets crazy but
you said yesterday that you weren't
gonna resign when senators asked you
this question
and i believe that you guys probably
won't resign you seem to be
very happy failing up over there
but if we didn't have a president that
was so adult
you all would be fired because that is
what you deserve you have let down the
people who wear the uniform in my
district and all around this country and
you're far more interested in what your
perception is and how people think about
you and insider washington books than
you care about winning this time has
been capable of doing
a miss houlhan is recognized
thank you mr chair and gentlemen i
apologize for the behavior of my
colleague
[Laughter]
it's just grandstanding this this does
nothing to move forward the interests of
the american people or of the united
states as a country globally um in this
next clip um donald trump's former
doctor ronnie jackson who's now a member
of congress also uh getting millie
completely exasperated
general milly will you now resign
i serve at the pleasure of the president
mr jackson
um congressman pat fallon from texas
uh asking milly about his comments about
that horribly botched drone strike in
afghanistan
and uh of course taking them completely
out of context and uh general millie on
september first three days later you
described it as a righteous strike
people that were not supposed to be
killed were killed and you described it
as a righteous strike
yeah if you go back and look at the full
quote what i said was we followed the
procedures
i had every reason to believe that um
that we followed our procedures at that
point in time we knew that there were
civilians killed we knew there were
non-combatants and there was uh
collateral damage yes you said were
others killed yes yes who are they we
don't know we're trying to sort through
all that right that's that's right
that's right because i believed kill
people we should know i believe it was
right
i believe that the target that we were
aiming for and i believe the target
was okay i have three more and uh and
this is a strategy which is you don't
even really give time to answer the
questions now i think i've already
spoken about the botched drone strike
and it's absolutely horrifying and
disgusting but the idea that suddenly
republicans care about drone strikes and
civilian deaths is laughable and then
last clip here's the previous day
this is senator tom cotton again
bringing up what why haven't there been
resignations got one final question
general nelly i can only conclude
that your advice
about staying in afghanistan was
rejected i'm shocked to learn that your
advice wasn't sought until august 25th
on staying past the august 31 deadline
i understand that you're the principal
military advisor that you advise you
don't decide the president decides
but if all this is true general milly
why haven't you resigned
senator
as a senior military officer
resigning is a really serious thing it's
a political act if i'm resigning in
protest my job is to provide advice my
statutory responsibilities provide legal
advice or best military advice to the
president and that's my legal
requirement so millie having to explain
to tom cotton sort of like how things
work we learned nothing from these
hearings what is the dollar value the
dollar cost of these hearings to just
allow these republicans to ask
why haven't you resigned essentially
without an interest even in learning
anything about what has actually taken
place just more pathetic behavior by
this modern republican party
i love segments like this next one today
we're going to go through some examples
of lying with graphs
um i've told you before all the
different ways you can lie with
statistics there's a book i've
recommended many times it's called how
to lie with statistics by daryl huff
not a new book but a very important book
to understand
uh in the book it talks about sampling
bias or selectively choosing when you
say average
choosing mean median or mode depending
on which is most convenient for the
point you're trying to make
uh it talks about post hoc ergo procter
hawk all of this stuff is in the book
but one of the chapters is called the
g-whiz graph it's a way to lie with
graphs and a classic in line with graphs
specifically
is truncating the y-axis or sometimes
the x-axis
the y-axis is the vertical axis on a
graph so think through just a general
example and then we'll look at what fox
news did in the last few days imagine i
want to give you the impression that the
temperature
just skyrocketed when it really didn't
now in the northeast of the united
states over the course of a year there's
a really broad temperature range you
know in winter there's some days where
it's minus five fahrenheit sometimes
you'll get a minus 10 fahrenheit day in
some parts of the northeast and yet in
the summer it can be like 100 degrees
fahrenheit on a really hot day during a
heat wave so that's a big range minus 10
to 100. if one day it's 72 degrees and
the next day it's 75 degrees that's not
a big change when you think about
sometimes it's minus 10.
sometimes it's 100
but if i plot the 72 and 75 degree days
and really shorten that y-axis so the
chart starts at 70 degrees and ends at
80 degrees
that 3 degree change between 72 and 75
will look absolutely huge so that gets
us to fox news these last few days and
we have multiple examples here the other
day in one of his segments about how the
united states is i guess going down the
tubes because not enough people are
religious anymore tucker carlson put up
this graph which we're putting up on the
screen which shows the percentage of
christians in the u.s in 2009 and the
percentage of christians in the u.s in
2019 and if you look at these yellow
bars
that looks like a big decline but if you
look at the y-axis you see that this
only starts at 58
and ends at 78 percent now of course
anywhere from zero to 100 percent of
americans could identify as christian
that's the range
but the chart makes the decline look
huge
by only showing you the scale 58 to 78.
now christianity is in decline of
religiosity is in decline in the united
states but it's not nearly as dramatic
as this chart makes it look to the
untrained eye now here's one other
example this is not truncating the
y-axis it's sort of shortening the time
horizon kind of like shortening the
x-axis in this case this was on the news
side of fox news not opinion
brett bayer newsman brett bayer showed
graphs that make it look like the cost
of oil and gas is just way way up under
joe biden
so they showed this graph of oil prices
and it shows that oil and gas sure
seemed to have been really low in 2020
under trump and then boom skyrocketing
under joe biden but the issue is it only
looks at 2019 through what we have so
far of 2021
then brett shows this graph of gas
prices which also shows only 2019 to
2021
and it looks like gas prices went down
in 2020 and then exploded in 2021 under
joe biden now this is deceptive for two
reasons the first is the pandemic the
pandemic hit and cratered demand for oil
and gas since people stopped traveling
and then the recovery started and so
demand went up and prices started going
up that's one reason why it's deceptive
that's a a qualitative reason but
quantitatively this is really deceptive
because oil prices have not uh oil
prices have been going up for about
seven years but they are still
historically not very high when you zoom
out and you look at a chart of oil
prices that goes back to like 1995 or so
you very quickly see
that prices skyrocketed around 2007 and
then came down
and then upper in 2012 and then came
down and now they're roughly at a seven
year high that started about seven years
ago it is not a joe biden thing so when
you zoom out you see oil prices are
nowhere near record highs
and number two they've been on an
increasing trend that is seven years old
now not
this year under biden very similar with
natural gas you zoom out to 1995
you see gas prices were higher in 2001
in 2006 and 2009 and yes they're up
again now
extremely deceptive always look at the
labels on the axes this is stuff every
12 year old should be taught
uh and if we started teaching this when
when kids were 12
way fewer people would fall for it on
fox news we'll have these graphs and
more examples on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman's show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show it's great to have
back on the program today dr isaac
bogosh an infectious diseases physician
and scientist based out of the
university of toronto and toronto
general hospital great having you back
again
great to see you again so where to even
start um okay i mean over the last uh
over the last month or so we've seen a
global decline of about 30 31 32 in
daily case average uh the u.s has seen a
similar decline some countries are a
little bit ahead of that some a little
bit behind um
what's the explanation here is it
vaccination getting to a critical point
is there still some seasonality we don't
understand is it just inaccurate
reporting and maybe cases aren't really
going down
yeah i think uh i think it's a lot of
the above in fact all of the above so
certainly in countries that have
significant vaccine access and vaccine
rollout that's definitely helping right
that's definitely keeping cases down or
driving cases down and we can't ignore
that but of course there's probably
other factors at play we know that
vaccine equity global vaccine equity is
a major issue there still are billions
of people around the world without
access to these vaccines mainly in
low-income countries and there are you
know in depending on where you are in
the world there are very significant
outbreaks and epidemics of this so
globally it's great to see those cases
go down um i think it's too soon to
start having you know mission
accomplished banners up or anything like
that we're still at a global level far
from the end but certainly in countries
with high vaccine uptake like the united
states like canada like many european
countries and the few countries in asia
yeah we are closer to the end we might
be in the second to third period rather
than in the first period like unfor some
other countries are so last summer of
2020 there was the correct belief that
the fall into winter in the northern
hemisphere was going to get pretty bad
at the time we were just starting to
roll out vaccines there was very limited
availability the peak ended up being in
the u.s it was basically january 20th
right around presidential inauguration
day in other countries it was a little
bit earlier a little bit later and uh
then we saw the the sort of big decline
and then we got the delta spike
this time around where vaccination
is available in many of these countries
and we're still not totally sure about
the seasonality matchup that that sort
of mirrors the flu's seasonality
what do we think about this fall and
winter in the northern hemisphere
right i think there's a couple of points
one is that when we talk about
seasonality it might mean different
things to different people and yes i'm
sure eventually
this virus will have a more seasonal
component maybe it'll be more present in
certain times of years like the colder
months versus the warmer months and and
that's you know that's very likely to
happen with time but when i'm talking
about seasonality now i'm i'm
oversimplifying it but it kind of can be
simplified in the sense that whatever
puts people indoors
uh is is a is a risk factor for greater
transmission hey it's cold outside and
it's september so kids are going back to
school many people are going back to
work in person and we're not hanging out
outdoors any as much anymore because
it's getting chilly we're spending
recreational time indoors and that in
and of itself at a population level can
certainly drive numbers up because
there's just innumerable opportunities
for this virus to be transmitted so when
we put that together and look at the
northern hemisphere yes it is getting
cooler people are going inside for more
and more reasons i think it's fair to
say that we will see peaks and valleys
but probably peaks throughout the cooler
months in the the fall and the winter in
the northern hemisphere and you know it
sort of stating the obvious i think
areas that have more widespread vaccine
uptake will have more blunted peaks so
the amplitude of those peaks is really
under our control in countries like
canada the united states that are
fortunate enough to have access to those
vaccines you can vaccinate yourself and
and those around you and your community
you can create safer indoor spaces as
well with masking with ventilation with
crowd control uh like there's a lot of
steps we can take to create safer indoor
spaces at a population level as well so
that you reap the benefits of of those
uh vaccination campaigns plus those
non-pharmaceutical interventions so
short story long yeah i mean we'll
probably have some peaks and valleys uh
throughout the fall and the winter but
how high those peaks go are under our
control we have the tools to keep this
under control
so
on speaking of tools there was a period
where it seemed as though every adult
was headed towards a third shot uh
originally the word booster was used but
when it was when the framing was no no
no it may be a three shot regimen the
change of language was it's not an it's
not a booster it's just part of what
you're supposed to do
and then all of a sudden we started
seeing a change in tone to some degree
where at least in the u.s the
recommendation changed to only third
shots for 65 plus
immunocompromised pre-existing
conditions which if you include being
overweight and smoking is a lot of
people in the united states right i mean
but let's put that aside just for a
second here um what's your sense of
because there's the medical question as
to who would really benefit there's a
vaccine equity question as to should
people be getting third shots or is are
those better used as first shots in
other parts of the world
how should we be thinking about it
david i love how you separate those
questions because oftentimes that gets
confused and from a medical standpoint
like this is a very valid medical
question do people need a third dose of
the vaccine and if we want to delve into
that i think the answer is like anything
else it's a bit more complicated um
i think there's good data to drive that
immunocompromised individuals however we
want to define it would benefit from a
third dose of a vaccine right they just
don't mount the same degree of an immune
response as other people and and as you
point out this could be viewed as you
know many people have had two doses of a
three dose regimen you need that third
dose for better protection we've known
this for a million years well before
covet 19 right there's a reason we give
uh immunocompromised individuals double
doses of for example the hepatitis b
vaccine like this is known
similar to that people who are on the
older end of the spectrum uh will
probably benefit from a third dose of a
vaccine in the united states it was
defined as 65 and up we could argue and
debate about the data but that's not
unreasonable including those who live in
congregate care settings like long-term
care facilities and again we've known
this long before coven 19 came around
there's a reason we give
older cohorts the higher dose influenza
vaccine every year because we know they
need an extra boost to mountain an
immune response but
i gotta say and i you know when we're
you know i'm sitting in canada now when
we were listening to the united states
discuss this if we were in mid-august we
heard very senior political and public
health leaders say
everyone's getting a booster shot at the
six month mark oops pardon us sorry
everyone's getting a booster at the five
month mark oops no no we meant six
months or eight months and then they
actually had to sit down and you had the
fda discuss it then you had the uh
vaccine experts discuss it like the
process to get to this decision was very
choppy and i think did a lot of damage
in terms of public trust in the vaccine
efforts especially when we know many
unvaccinated people currently uh
uh you know we're for lack of a better
word we're trying to win them over we're
trying to show and demonstrate how safe
and effective and reasonable it is to
get these vaccines this didn't do a lot
of good in the in in getting to that
point unfortunately the other thing too
is
i don't know where it really landed in
the united states because it seems like
you know if you're a smoker if you're
obese if you may
work in a higher risk setting you can it
basically seems like it's open season
and anyone who wants to get a third dose
can get a third dose i don't think
that's that's really appropriate i'm not
to blab on and on but then let's factor
in
the equity issue you've got hundreds of
millions of people that are eligible for
a third dose when there's billions of
people who haven't received the first
dose and hundreds or tens of millions of
americans that should be receiving a
first dose you want to get this under
control you get first and second doses
in as many people as possible rather
than third doses not to ignore that
there are some people who would really
benefit from a third dose so to sum it
all up
do we all need third doses now no we
don't do some of us need third doses now
yes some of us do
will we all need a third dose at some
point in the future yeah we might all
need a third dose at some point in the
future but we don't all need a third
dose now so in terms of protection level
which as you point out can be in terms
of larger populations
the protection level is lower for
certain folks and that's a factor in
thinking about these third doses
how should we be thinking now about how
protected one is
today
given the difference between the
dominant delta strain and what was the
original or live strain for which the
vaccines were calculated because
you
hear
you still got a mask if you're
vaccinated because you can still spread
it and then you hear hey actually you
can but if you're vaccinated and
asymptomatic
it's not super likely but it's but it's
possible and it makes it makes it very
difficult to do like a risk assessment
of any individual so
when you read 99 98 97 of the cases and
and or at least hospitalizations are in
the unvaccinated
what does that tell us
yeah basically you know sometimes people
complain about shifting goal posts and
you're changing the rules and the answer
is yes of course they're shifting goal
posts of course you're changing the
rules and adapting policy you have to
because the virus has changed as well
and the delta variant is of course it's
the same virus but it functions in a
different manner it's way more
transmissible versus compared to the
original virus that emerged from wuhan
so yes you have to have these shifting
goal posts the problem is communicating
this and and telegraphing uncertainty
and and communicating that there will be
changes over time some we can expect
some we not we might not be able to
expect so that people don't feel like
they're getting the rug pulled from
underneath them so that's that's that's
one important point the second point
though is
yeah i mean delta is much more
transmissible but we do know that
if you're vaccinated right off the bat
delta or not well especially even with
delta you still reduce the risk of
getting copin 19 you reduce the risk of
getting
infected but you greatly reduce your
risk of getting really sick like landing
in hospital needing an icu or dying and
and there's just overwhelming data from
multiple countries demonstrating all
this the second point is
you can still get infected uh
with delta even if you're vaccinated
we've known that we've known that long
before delta even emerged in the
original clinical trials that were
published there were still vaccinated
people that got infected delta hadn't
even emerged yet so that's not new uh
but we do know now that if you are
vaccinated and infected
you're just much less likely to transmit
to other people of course you can still
transmit but the problem probability is
lower so you know for example if you
want to create a safe indoor space a
restaurant a bar a casino a daycare or
wherever the more vaccinated people you
have that indoor space you just reduce a
the likelihood that you're bringing
cover 19 into that space and b though if
it is brought in the likelihood that
it's transmitted to other people
of course that's one significant layer
of protection but we have to think of
this as layers of protection there's
other layers you can take masking
ventilation crowd control and when you
put all those layers together and you
add that to vaccines you want to get
really fancy add rapid testing at the
door the more layers you have the safer
the indoor space you have the more
layers you peel off you're just adding
incremental levels of risk and you've
got to find that sweet spot of what's
reasonable what's convenient and what's
necessary for that particular
environment
last thing i want to touch on
when do cases no longer matter in a very
specific sense i think it was with uh
h1n1
that at a certain point when it was
determined that it's no more deadly than
the flu strain of that year and correct
me if it's not h1n1 but it was a
different thing that i'm referring to um
at a certain point the testing stopped
because it didn't really matter whether
you had the flu or you had again i think
it was h1n1 because the protocol was no
different it was no more deadly the case
numbers may have been interesting but
they didn't really tell us anything
about the risk to an individual of
getting really sick from being out in
the world
does it depend on the level of
vaccination does it depend on the maybe
reduced severity of
coronavirus as we go forward which may
happen or or it may not when do the case
numbers no longer matter
so i i think if you lined up 20 people
in the business you'd probably get
several different answers the way i
think about this though is
i like the case numbers but it has to be
put into the appropriate context right
there's a lot of data hospitalizations
icu's deaths cases vaccinated percent
positive blah blah blah blah blah
context is important so you have to put
the appropriate weight and and context
to each data point but when the case
numbers sort of start to
lower in the importance factor i think
it's in my mind it's really when we
start to see this virus not impact our
society as much anymore what do you mean
by that it's not resulting in an
overwhelming number of hospitalizations
or deaths or morbidity it's not
preventing people from doing what they
do and a lot of that's a value judgment
as well right there's a value judgment
here
it's it's kind of unfortunate and
disgusting to think about but at some
point we're going to have to
collectively decide
what is an acceptable
number of deaths per year right for
covet 19. not nice to think about but we
have to figure that out like in canada
for example influenza kills 3 500 people
per year awful terrible get your flu
shot all of them are tragic
but
as a country we've sort of come to terms
with that's about how many we see per
year we have to come to terms with how
many coven 19
deaths or cases or what is quote unquote
acceptable and like again these some
will say zero
i i don't think that's practical uh of
course there's the letter rip crowd i
don't think that's safe or ethical as
well but eventually enough people have
immunity through vaccination or recovery
from infection that it just doesn't pose
a a a burden on the country or the
region as much as it used to you're not
going to overwhelm your health care
system you can go to restaurants and
bars
live your life but
it's the virus isn't going away so it's
going to be a bit of a value judgment
that's a bit of a long-winded way of
answering that question but at some
point as long as it when it's when it
impacts the country or the region less
by not overwhelming the health care
system and not causing
meaningful morbidity and mortality
that's probably when the case counts
don't matter yeah and it will still be
an a different call for different
individuals also based on their uh their
their level of risk and their
willingness to accept risk as well so
there's no it's a it's a complex answer
because it's a complex question i guess
is the way we would say it uh we've been
speaking with dr isaac bogosh infectious
diseases physician and scientist based
at the university of toronto and toronto
general hospital always great catching
up with you
great to chat david
follow the david pakman show on social
media interact with me and other david
pakman show viewers you'll be able to
see when we're taking calls live on the
show we post hilarious video clips
you'll see exclusive show content not on
the show and you'll be the first to see
big announcements like upcoming guests
and more follow me on twitter at
deepakman and davidpakmanshow we're on
instagram david.pakman join the reddit
community at davidpakman.com reddit and
you can also find the david pakman show
on facebook
discord and tick tock it's almost too
easy
we have a really interesting political
situation
that surfaced in the last um 24 to 48
hours
a poll came out from the perennially
unreliable rasmussen reports which says
that if the 2024 election were held
today
uh and donald trump were the republican
nominee and joe biden were the
democratic nominee donald trump would
defeat biden by 10 points 51 to 41.
now what is interesting about this other
than you know it's three years out and a
poll right now is sort of meaningless
there are two things that are very
interesting one is
i don't actually disagree with the
general conclusion and that conclusion
is that donald trump might easily win in
2024 against joe biden i've actually
said before
when i think about 2024 big picture
i don't really see joe biden at age 81
days short of his 82nd birthday in
november of 2024
defeating donald trump after four years
of trumpists talking about how terrible
joe biden is i see it as a big uphill
battle
if biden says
no thanks i'm not running for reelection
but kamala harris is the nominee as of
right now kamala harris's approval
rating is not good
and i don't see kamala defeating donald
trump in a general election either and
that's why i've been saying the best
scenario is donald trump not running in
2024
but that doesn't change that this poll a
rasmussen poll
three years out
is really not worth much at all but all
the normal star stuff starts happening
when the poll comes out
the washington examiner starts writing
headlines about the poll trump over
biden by 10 points harris by 13.
trump then publishes
a reference on his website to the poll
and a link to this very same washington
examiner article
and the ecosystem starts to repeat
itself and build on itself so this is a
sort of weird situation because
i think trump could absolutely win
in 2024
but without knowing what happens in 2022
and what the next you know at least 18
months of the joe biden presidency look
like it is very hard to say anything
substantive about the specifics of trump
versus biden in 2024 are republican
voters ignorant enough to elect donald
trump again absolutely of course they
are
um
which is why it would be better for
donald trump not to run and whatever
that reason is trump becoming convinced
that he can't win when i was on the
michael cohen podcast a few weeks ago or
maybe six weeks ago something like that
michael cohen said i don't think trump
will run because he can't handle another
disappointment he can't handle another
hit to his ego he just he just can't
handle it and so he doesn't want the
chance of losing again and he's not
going to run but at the same time trump
is a major narcissist and it takes a lot
for trump to think he can't win trump
tends to think he can win he tends to
think of himself as invincible
and that to me signals that he very well
may run unless it's abundantly clear
that he has no shot it would be better
for trump not to run because there's no
question that the american public
as a result of its composition with so
many low information radicalized
republicans would vote for trump again
at least plausibly the message here
is that the exact coalition that brought
biden his victory in 2020 which came
down to
not that many votes in a few states
remember massive um popular vote victory
bigger margin than trump when it came to
electoral not in electoral votes but the
combined margin in the states that made
a difference it was a few hundred
thousand rather than just the 77 000
votes in three states that pushed trump
over 270
but biden's coalition was very
precarious a slight departure from it
could have seen donald trump reelected
and that's not a threat that should be
understated so
do we care about rasmussen three years
out no not specifically the polling is
bogus but
the message that trump could definitely
win in 2024
is an accurate message and that's the
one that we should be paying attention
to hey i don't know how i missed this
this was a few days ago but yesterday
people sent me clips and i do want to
talk about it because there's some
interesting stuff here uh a a uh i was
gonna say a journalist a man named dan
ball from oan one american news had a
one-on-one interview with donald trump
apparently the interview was very long
and it was a bizarre interview in every
way
and i think there's a few interesting
things here and i want to look at them
with you let's start with the first clip
where donald trump again pushes the big
lie that he actually won in 2020
and then claims the country's not
actually going to survive this now that
has some interesting implications let's
listen again you know i don't want to be
naive i think they're grossly
incompetent i really do i don't think
it's of us because they cheat on the
elections they don't need votes they
cheat on the elections i mean you look
at 43 000 votes were found last night
they cheat on elections when you cheat
on elections you don't have to destroy
the country they're destroying our
country our country
will not survive this our country will
not survive and what does that mean the
country the country won't survive what
it won't survive joe biden being
president for four years what what
exactly is it that the country won't
survive and what's the timeline and it's
funny how these hyperbol uh these
right-wingers claim the left is
hyperbolic when the left says
there is a timeline on dealing with
climate change after which we could hit
a point of no return they say look at
that hyperbole and then trump says the
country's not going to survive this what
do you mean look at where they're coming
from they're coming from yemen they're
coming from the middle east they're
coming from all countries that are very
sick countries very sick
very
mean
nasty
they're coming from
all countries that have so trump getting
visibly confused there and this goes
back to immigration and the unproven
idea that terrorists from yemen and
other countries are coming through the
u.s mexico border we still have no
evidence of that it could happen
theoretically that could happen we have
no evidence that that's actually taking
place
trump then sang again his line about the
cupboards were bare when he took over
but saying nobody could have predicted a
pandemic just could no who could have
predicted it masks
we were doing what we did all of the
cupboards were bare including the u.s
cupboard the governors didn't have
anything we didn't because nobody really
ever thought a pandemic would happen
it sounds like sort of an ancient thing
you know or go back of course no one
could have predicted a pandemic
other than the pandemic response team
which trump disbanded when he became
president
and they even left a playbook about what
to do in the case of a pandemic which
they threw out 1917 which was so bad oh
and trump also mentioning the 1917 flu
which was of course in 1918 very very
strange stuff
then the interview moves on and oan host
dan ball
feeds the idea to trump that joe biden
is shipping people in from the middle
east to red states
to try to cheat an election just i mean
the interviewer feeding trump conspiracy
theories why do you think and this is
another thing just talking like about
the middle east why would the biden
administration want to allow by the end
of this year by most figures i've looked
up it's going to be 1.5 2 million
by the end of the year why would you
want to do that are you trying to that
and we see we're shipping them they're
shipping to the midwest the south ship i
mean listen is there more dehumanizing
language than saying you're shipping
people like it's a computer red states
mostly is this a planned for another way
to cheat at elections so they say it's
the votes but i don't think so again you
know i don't want to be naive i think
they're grossly incompetent then it gets
into the segment that uh that we looked
at earlier um you have to understand
that they continue to insist
undocumented immigrants from latin
america are coming here in order to vote
and cheat in elections undocumented
immigrants
or non-citizens of any kind can't vote
and similarly
if an asylum seeker or refugee gets here
uh from afghanistan or wherever
um they can't vote they are not citizens
at least not initially there's a long
process there and so this is completely
and totally made up
um then they get into the cova death
toll is inflated it's not they continue
to repeat this one we did a great job in
addition we report
all of our covid at a level that nobody
in the world does if somebody's dying of
a heart attack and dying of cancer
and they're somewhere close to being uh
somebody with covet they put it down as
cove now that's a lie that's it is not
true
that if you have a heart attack
and your sister had coveted and you die
from the heart attack they say you died
of covet because you're cis that it's
just not true because believe it or not
the doctors get more money yes can we
please now that's also not true
what this goes back to is the fact that
it's more expensive to treat covid
patients on average
and so medicare
pays more money to hospitals that are
treating because the hospitals incur
greater costs and are doing more things
it's a complete lie that by just
claiming someone has covered you get
more money that it's been widely
debunked that because that has upset me
and i think millions of americans well
it's upset people but it's a lie for the
last 18 months this 623 000 death toll
and the lovely and we'll get to see them
in a minute the fake news their lovely
death ticker they head up the last 18
months scaring the bejesus out of
american citizens i think to me is
treasonous but that's another story for
another day with you well the death
counters are treason you have it by the
way and but it's not six twenty three is
it's not because it died and died from
and by the way if you look at china's
real numbers and if you look at other
real numbers all right so you guys
understand what's going on there just an
outrageous interview where it's often
just trump telling the lies but in this
one
the interviewer is
is as much of a participant in the lies
um and then lastly really wacky
trump suggests that fox news was part of
a conspiracy to steal the election from
him
and then
i'm upset in arizona and fox called it
early when i was leading big what did
fox know to do that
before we wrap things up here i want to
give a big thank you to not only
president donald j trump yeah so how how
did fox know to call it early
a wacky interview and unfortunately
people are watching oan people are
watching this stuff
uh very very concerning and uh the
it
it's too radical for fox news
understand that they now criticize fox
news as part of the problem and it's
only newsmax and oan that will really
tell you the truth crazy
uphill battle that we are fighting here
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
one of our viewers researched the
origins of the coronavirus and uh he
figured it out take a listen to this
hi david i've been doing my own research
and investigating the
oranges of the coronavirus yes i've been
through many
forums i've been on grabber i've been on
parlor i've been on facebook
and i finally gotten to the bottom of it
it was antifa
exactly yeah no and the the you should
see when people say they're doing
research
you should see the things they're doing
and what they're looking at often
research is my aunt posted a conspiracy
article to facebook
and i read through all the comments and
nobody made any good counterpoints that
counts as research in some circles we've
got a great bonus show for you today los
angeles is moving towards banning the
unvaccinated from most businesses we
will talk about the biden administration
again trying to end trump's remain in
mexico policy and obesity rates way up
during the pandemic we'll explain the
why
and the how some of it obvious some less
obvious get instant access to today's
bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com i'll see you
then
you